in myanmar
slingshots against bullets
junta forces have killed more than 450
people
air strikes over the weekend forcing
thousands from their homes
while some fled to the nearby forest
many others crossed the border to
thailand
hoping for refuge this group of men
women and children
are among them but activists say the
protection they sought has been denied
they claim more than 2 000 have been
sent back
to the homes they ran from
thailand is training the myanmar
military
the thai companies are doing business
with the myanmar military
and they provide political support to
the
myanmar military so thailand is backing
the people who are causing the refugees
and then punishing the refugees when
they have to flee the violence and
attacks
from the military today the thai
authorities denied any such pushback
and said they would continue to look
after refugees
the prime minister said earlier the
country was preparing to accept them
please let this be an internal issue for
us we don't want to have an exodus of
refugees
or even evacuations into our territory
but we will observe human rights too
today our path to the refugees was
blocked thai military saying
access was restricted due to covert 19.
but locals told us they believe more
people are preparing to cross the border
the bank on the far side of the river
there is in myanmar so for people who
are running for their lives thailand
is tantalizingly close but not all
routes here
are safe we're told the buildings on the
top of that hill are an army base
belonging to the myanmar military
but as the death toll in myanmar
continues to mount
people will look for anywhere they can
find safety
siobhan robbins sky news on the thai
border